in this episode of cloud performance
atlas I helped some social savants with
their data store performance we still on
for performance game night stay tuned to
find out friend set is building a
standard run-of-the-mill mobile social
media platform however as their user
load started to rise they notice that
the time it takes to retrieve social
post started to get longer and longer
after a few hours of profiling and
working with their team we quickly saw
the issue although their client was only
getting part of the fetch data their
server was fetching the full data per
entity from datastore and as the list
got larger their performance got worse
see by default cloud datastore will
return entire entities as the result of
a query and most developers haven't yet
found that projection queries can
actually help them we see a lot of
implementations with datastore that
looks something like this a user makes a
request and datastore fetches the
relevant entities then some front-end
prunes the entity properties and passes
on only the relevant data back to the
requesting client sadly though this is a
slow way to do things I mean you're
fetching the full entities and then
taking the time to trim them down for
those situations where you might not
need all of the properties returned from
an entity projection queries allows
datastore to return only what you need
rather than fetching everything and
having to do the culling yourself for
example if you need to access only the
keys from a query results use a keys
only query this can be really helpful in
situations where you need to do a keys
only query first and then fetch a subset
of entities based on the results from
that rather than executing a larger
general query likewise using projections
your query returns abridged results with
only the specified properties populated
with values once again since the query
is only returning a subset of data you
can end up in a more performant position
now for friend set we had to do a few
fancier things but sadly we don't have
time to cover all of that here instead
checkout the datastore queries page
where you find a whole list of
optimizations for your queries that can
help in every situation you might find
yourself in and don't forget to check
out the rest of the cloud performance
Atlas content because when it comes to
performance
every millisecond counts